AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, NOT
TONIGHT, I HAVE AN EXCUSE.
HAVE YOU EVER HAD TO COME UP
WITH AN EXCUSE TO NOT HAVE SEX?
NOPE, ME, EITHER.
BUT APPARENTLY, SOME PEOPLE DO
IT ALL THE TIME.
THIS WEEK, HUFFINGTON POST
PUBLISHED THE 10 MOST COMMON
EXCUSES TO AVOID SEX.
I MEAN, SHE'S NOT HAVING SEX
WITH HIM BECAUSE HE'S CLEARLY A
DOUCHEBAG.
COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
COME UP WITH AS MANY EXCUSES AS
YOU CAN TO AVOID SEX.
60 SECONDS AND BEGIN!
WILL.
>> I'M SORRY, BUT I'M SO FULL OF
HOT HAM AND CHEESE.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HORATIO.
>> COMO SE CHURRO PENIS?
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
WILL.
>> SORRY, HON, I JUST HAD A TON
OF SEX ACROSS THE STREET.
>> CHRIS: KRISTEN.
>> SURE, WE CAN HAVE SEX: FIST
OR KNEES?
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
KRISTEN.
>> MY DICK HURTS!
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
A FAIR EXCUSE, MADAM.
KRISTEN.
>> OH, NO, I ONLY DO THAT FOR
MONEY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.